congratulations his season three you get
an iconic role and made it your own how
much fun are you having yeah I'm having
fun I think I'd finally say that and I
can be truthful I'm really having a good
time it's okay took me three seasons to
get disciplined enough to enjoy it but
I'm finally there and there's such a
great relationship between you and the
whole cast really and that relationship
between Jack and angus is such a great
chemistry how is it on set for you guys
is it to a point now you guys are just
goofing off or actually when you get
George and Justin and I in the same room
yeah it's like three outlaws and then no
one can control us and Justin's a
stand-up comedian and George is has all
the capabilities of one and so it's it's
just really funny I mean it's amazing
that we get any work done when they're
around so but the whole cast is really
really great I mean you have to it's not
like on a movie where you spent six
weeks with each other and if you don't
like each other well the work was great
but on this you have to at least in some
way get along with the people that you
work with
so season three what can fans expect
with MacGyver well you can expect much
more intense action we're doing a lot
more practical stuff so instead of me
being in a sidecar and motorcycle on a
green screen going hey Jack catch this
where and there's a fan blowing in my
hair where actually I was on a
motorcycle in real life there's a
beginning of season three I had a stunt
where they let me do it I'd worked with
a stunt team on a movie called monster
trucks a lot of practical stuff there
and so you know they do all the fast and
furious movies so I'm on a I'm on a car
I'm used to green screen stuff on our
show cuz they had to keep me safe so
they strap me underneath the car on the
side of it with a wire from here coming
out of my shirt and then I just drugged
me on the side of the car for like you
know like a quarter-mile adrenaline rush
right oh yeah I love doing my own stunts
it's funny cuz I had this major like I
was showing us off earlier I got I've
rolled my ankle and I got this deep cut
into my thumb and none of those are from
the stunts that's just from my own my
own personal time
yeah is there gonna be some romance for
MacGyver in season three oh yeah we
started we started off I think first
seem is romance I saw it yesterday I
know what scene you're talking about
Harry romance yeah that's a cryptic hey
there's a meaning to that it sounds
gross look I have a beard start off with
a beard I look like Grizzly Adams and I
have a love interest right off the bat
right off the bat and the dad
relationship is that gonna grow ever
gonna see more of their interaction
together oh yeah you'll you'll see I
don't want to spoil anything but yes you
will see Mac and Mac and Mac Mac and Mac
joining forces and doing some stuff
together at first out of spite but but
yeah and then they're really ship may or
may not grow up I'm not gonna ruin it
you're killing it you know that what
you're just you're just everywhere
movies and and TV and the show is so
good people are really enjoying it I
hope so yeah they are
what kick-started your career well
that's a real boring answer that I got
for ya I I like when I was a kid and
I've said this so many times that's why
I feel like it's boring III was too
small to play football right and I moved
around a lot and finally and I just
needed something to do my mom was like
you didn't even outlet so there was
there was like a an acting school that
like would just kind of it almost seemed
like it would just go to the phone book
and just call random people and then we
got a call and then I auditioned they
got a local an audition for a local
agent there in Atlanta from what's where
I grew up
and yeah just long story short from then
on yeah they just kept going that was
when I was 10 so it goes to ten and then
the whole Taylor Swift thing happens you
know what's 10 years
oh that's impossible that's in Betances
imagine the videos that's 10 years ago
that's crazy
that's really fascinating yeah yeah they
must be that's that but that would
explain a lot because just cuz I'm
getting older doesn't mean that that
video and Hannah Montana the movie
doesn't still play on my feet
something there swear there's still 13
year old girls that like come up and
they're like how do you know that yeah
did you watch the original MacGyver um
yeah I admit it mmm I mean yes but not
not like I was familiar and I had seen
episodes but not certainly not a lot and
I think that kind of helped me going in
because everyone has like what's it
what's it like what's a pressure like
man I don't know man I can't think about
that right now I'm trying to just do my
job
I'll be honest I did not think that the
pilot was going to go I was like well
you know it was a cool opportunity at
that point and when I my manager had got
me to read it it was like it is it was a
great pilot the original two and then
they they were shooting in Portland the
portal is my favorite city so he's like
I was like yes but make a paycheck and
go to port take a pic Duff was like okay
all right here we go all right I guess
I'm reprising up a love character see
how this goes